right it's on
three o'clock
welcome alex
thank you mr chair i had noted here no
that's right and i hope the test went
well
i did i passed
thanks
right welcome everybody to the march 15
extraordinary infrastructure services
committee meeting
today we are going over the
recommendations
for the new cultural facility
the way it's going to work is we're
going to have a report from steve
gibling
where you can heal
he'll give the report and then questions
can be asked
obviously would be a good time
with the recommendations in front of you
if you wanted to ask questions there and
then it might be speed things up
then the recommendations will be put
some of them will be put
in groups but if you do
if if you feel strongly that one needs
to be singled out then that's fine i
will do that if you'd like to raise that
so i'm going to start with there are no
apologies on zoom
we have
lindsey mckenzie
councillor clark
and we've also got michael morris
okay um
steve
no
no peter no thank you mr chair good
afternoon your worship uh councillors
uh look i'm gonna walk through this
report and i'm gonna focus on a couple
of areas of the report uh that are
significant to the decisions that you're
asked to make today
but before i do
i'd like to make a couple of
acknowledgements firstly
i'd like to acknowledge the
amazing effort that the museum
governance group
have put into this process and you'll
see through the report
uh the work that they've led and
championed has given us some pretty
clear evidence and advice
in support of our decision making and
some thanks goes to those
volunteers
for the time and contribution they've
made since august and a lot of that was
done via zoom as we're in lockdown
so i would like to acknowledge that
i'd also like to recognize that this is
actually a very significant decision or
the first step in a very significant
decision
the amount of information that the team
have put together and some of those team
members are represented around the room
today are here to answer any questions
you've got
but also to recognize from council's
point of view that this as a project
that has been
around for some time and we hope today
that you get confidence in the level of
data and information we've provided
you and that that helps you make those
decisions in which we consult with the
community but lead to a final option
that we can agree on in june this year
there's
three key recommendations for me and i'm
going to talk to those in a moment but i
will talk specifically to recommendation
4 and that is around the vision and
critical success factors
you'll note in them
the recommendation that we are proposing
one very minor amendment and when i get
to that i'll just touch on what that is
i'd also like to note that
recommendation 11 i just like to get a
correction
that council is not able to secure not
our
apologies we just want to make sure that
we get all our eyes dotted and our t's
crossed on this
so if you're a comfortable mischief i'm
just going to
go to page 10 of our report which is
addressing the vision and critical
success factors and this is one of those
key
decisions in this report
these elements are critical because they
don't just focus on what the service and
the experience is
but they also do a lot of leadership
towards what the design of the new
facility should look like
and the way in which the design team and
the museum governance group worked on
this was trying to
establish a vision but recognise that we
need both the service and the facility
to support one another
so
our focus is on exploring the stories of
southland that is the vision for this
new facility
and there are seven critical success
factors there and i'm just going to
touch on them briefly
the first one is about connecting with
our place with our land scene sky
it's around establishing an immersive
and contemporary experience
that is going to leave people with a
deeper connection to our place and this
is a
about building not only knowledge
but also civic pride and awareness of
the amazing space that we do live in
we've also with involving we are talking
here about this is very much about
connecting people
this is not just displaying artifacts
in the traditional sense of the old
museum
this is about connecting people
it's about making sure it's inclusive
and our exhibit exhibits and our place
is accessible
that we appeal to all wages cultures and
demographics
we recognize that this facility and
we've heard this through the feedback
from the community as this facility is
about people and that sense of loss it's
about the loss of our connection and so
we this is very much a people-centric
approach
inspiring is about telling our narrative
or a story through people and time
rather than just having a sequence of
artifacts
stored so we are looking at we are going
to create that immersive experience we
are going to look to tell the story of
southland
but is about
all the elements of that story it's not
just what artifact do we put on display
in terms of aspiring this speaks to our
education
this is about promoting a curiosity and
sparking that learning enquiry not only
for people and the steam
which is science technology education
arts and mathematics this is not about
formal education
it's it is about formal and informal
education we want us we want to create
people and opportunities for people to
come to this place
throughout the year and we've heard that
this museum used to be the wet weather
destination of invercargill
and actually what we want to be is the
destination for invercargill in all
weather
and that means that we've got to keep
drawing people in through the way in
which we tell our stories
through the artifacts the art through
the technology and the services in our
staff and bringing all of those elements
together in one piece
protecting
speaks to the fact we want to create a
safe environment and this is not just
around the building
itself on on queens park but that also
speaks especially in options two and
three
to the storage facility
around engaging we want a highly
flexible space
so we aren't going to be creating
traditional spaces where it is for art
and art only and nothing else should go
in there
or artifact only and we keep those
barriers up because of the way in which
we've designed the facility or
constrained by the facility
we're looking for services in the
building to be flexible to our community
now and to be able to respond to the
future needs of the community in 20 30
and 40 years time
it means we've got to be efficient with
the way in which we design our spaces
around floor area and the systems to
enable our future reconfigurations
rather constrain us
and finally this has got to produce
value
for the community both in a financial
sense but that sense of civic pride so
we're really trying to balance the
investment that the community is going
to be asked to put into this as well as
our third party funders
so the critical success factors have
been developed by the museum governance
group and have been tested and supported
by our staff
we have then used those vision and
critical success factors to then give to
our design team to come up with these
spatial options that you've got on the
mgg report
these critical success factors have then
formed our test against the three
options and i'm just going to touch on
the options now
so option one
is a full refurbishment of the current
facility
option one gets us to 67
of the building standards
it addresses the structural issues of
highest concern but it doesn't avoid
repair requirements in the event of a
future seismic event
critically it doesn't comply with the
vision and critical success factors or
the functional brief that we have
developed
option two
would see the current facility
demolished and a replacement building
positioned within the current footprint
on queen's park
it also includes a new permanent
stand-alone storage facility as well as
part of that
package
and option three
essentially is just a smaller option
compared to option two
however smaller doesn't mean
a poorer outcome
that 600 meter reduction in space means
that we would see smaller areas within
the public and education spaces and
within the temporary and special
exhibition areas
and it will also see
a reduction in on-site staff facilities
and workshop
but from a community and customer point
of view these changes do not adversely
affect our ability to deliver on the
vision and critical success factors
it just means we've got to be a little
bit more flexible with our design and
our service approach
in terms of the assessments between
options one two and three i'm going to
just touch on a couple of those
differences
option one will have a limited capacity
to deliver on a captivating or immersive
experience whereas options two and three
will achieve a hundred percent of those
visions or that vision and critical
success factors that have been set out
option one will have a limited capacity
to support steam and the education
programs
whereas options two and three will
likely grow
the potential for learning within and
outside the classroom
option one will not be able to
facilitate any touring exhibitions
whereas options two will be able to
accommodate nearly all national and
international touring exhibitions
option three will be able to accommodate
most but not all shows compared with
option two
option one has limited opportunities to
reshape the facility because of the
structural work that we have to do to
strengthen it
so we are unlikely to be able to provide
a more engaging and connecting customer
experience with in queens park
whereas options 2 and 3
our new builds will be designed with
that purpose solely in
mind option three however will be
slightly more constrained
but again this requires a more flexible
approach to the design
option one is unable to provide for a
functional space for staff to support
the vision
option three will mostly support that
functional back of house requirement
but that might be spread across across
both the storage and the new tarano
facility
whereas option two provides all of those
functional elements within the building
as noted in the report the museum
governance group
has discounted option one
they've made no comment on option
three and their preferred option is
option two
you'll note that staff have a different
view on that
and that is partly down to the fact that
the museum governance group
we're not asked to consider the
financial constraints that you're going
to be asked to consider
that includes the third party funding
and the achievability of that
third-party funding gap
in order to include the rates impact on
our community
and so these are things that the staff
have taken into account in coming up
with our preferred option
i've i think i've made all of the
statements i wish to make to the report
and
i'm happy to take any questions chair
okay thank you steve um what i'm going
to do now is
i'm going to move that we received the
report
for the new cultural facility foreign
can i have something to please
counselor sopa i'm going to put that all
those in favor hi
thank you right um i'm going to open the
floor now for questions
for steve
marcus
to see if he's going to go i apologize
no i haven't seen any hair oh yes nobody
i can see the yellow marker
yeah thank you chair um and apologies
steve but i have quite a few questions
as you can imagine um an excellent
report um and a series of reports that
we've got are here and and pe
um
and it's a good steer on where we go
forward but i do have some questions
that i'd like some clarification so be
with me as i work my way through it
um
so in the proposal is it your view that
this
museum or cultural center should be a
regional facility or an invicable city
facility
yeah thank you councillor
look this the vision that's been set out
it's recognizing it's telling the
stories of southland
but we also recognize
that the facility sits within an
invercargill context
so
to answer it it does both
but we do it through a lens of
invercargill i guess why i ask that
steve is because
your report also does reflect
that 67 to 80 of the
funding will come from the city
i guess if it wants to have a reason a
regional lens that may open some future
discussion about how the other councils
might
maybe approach to contribute a little
bit more to the uh to the overall cost
of the bill
but anyway thanks for that
um
when we get to the consultation
part of the annual plan
uh are you intending to
consult on
the storage location
are you putting in
places other than tisbury so we can have
a look at for arguments like the tennis
courts beside the current permit
yeah thank you councillor um the
following paper will deal with the
consultation approach for tisbury
reserve
and that commences that
reserve management act process
we aren't seeking any alternative sites
at this stage through the consultation
on the basis of all the advice and the
analysis that have been undertaken
around locations around the city
hopefully
sorry
so bear with me on that issue because my
preferred option was the tennis court
some time ago
and the advice we got from staff was
that that would require a land use
change
i think uh councillor ludlow gave some
insight into that
um
but it seems that the tasmanian also
requires it as well so i just want to
move with the
whether as part of consultation you will
open up the options or are we just
saying that's the decision
and that's where we're going to
one other one of the conversations that
tested the museum governance group last
year was around
the appropriateness of building a
purpose-built storage facility on
queen's park
and
you may recall some workshops we've had
where we talked about the storage
facility
it has a completely different function
to a cultural facility or a or a new
tayanura for one of a better word
the
the building from a storage point of
view doesn't engage public
it has to be seismically resilient and
therefore it's going to be a very simple
design it's not going to have windows
it's going to be as basic a structure as
we can afford
to store the collection and that has a
different approach especially if you put
that on queen's park which is you know
as we know an award-winning park
it's where do you best put that type of
facility
and we felt at that time that queen's
park wasn't appropriate
should we go down options two and three
the footprint can accommodate tayanila
and the current lease agreement but if
you were to add in a storage facility on
top of that footprint we would be
outside of that footprint and would then
need to do a reclassification on queen's
park
okay thank you for that in page three of
your your report you talk about um
the name for the new
facility point of view it's taught in
the museum now um
has not been determined yet
and i'm just wondering whether it would
be helpful to um not leave that for a
later date
um and why i say that is that
when we talked to the
mgg group there was some discussion
about
the days have gone by where we actually
call museums museums any longer
and so i thought quite like the
wording of the cargo cultural centre i
think that that opens it up beyond
potentially just a museum and it could
have a terrio name attached as well
um the two could run hamlet i'm just
wondering whether it would be good to
give some thought about
a name sooner than later
uh that might be something for the
council to determine uh rather than for
me today yeah just just seeking your
view steve um
on page five
it refers to um
us financially
potentially breaching our net debt limit
and the report in two or three places
uh refers to this which is the 150
of income that we set some time again
and i just want to get this cleared up
because i mean
to lay people looking in on these papers
they'd say oh well you're going above
your affordability level but that's not
true at all our council has
a very good
fiscal
track record
and that was set at a time when the
upper ceiling for local government
funding agency was 200
but that's now 300 so
it just seems to be a bit of a shackle
that we keep having and i just wonder
whether with the reports going forward
that whether you you feel that maybe as
a group of councillors we should
um remove that 150 or alternatively push
it up to 200 and then revisit it later
in the long term plan i really uh
councillor clark i don't think that is
actually a question yeah for uh steve so
i'm going to pass that across patricia
thank you councillor yes you're correct
we have set the limit at 150 because
that is currently what our policy says
that the limit is
that policy could be reviewed at a later
date
yeah i agree that it's
not i don't believe it's relevant to
this discussion but
when you raise it that is something that
can come up in ppp later on
absolutely thank you
on page 16 you refer to
us having to underwrite the thing and
this might be another one for patricia i
guess um
and and depending on what external
funding we're here
and i appreciate that but there seems to
be no nothing in the discussion paper
about
the possible use of reserves on a stress
that we're possible
a possible sign of an investment
property or two
and
again
councillor clark i think we're
digressing from what we actually the
recommendations are here because we are
not talking about how this is being
actually financed it's quite clear
the procedure we're going through to the
annual plan
any time to
discuss that would be when we do the
annual plan sorry about that
that's all right thank you very chair
um
the last thing i guess stephen the most
important one for me is the timing of
the storage project which you've got on
this paper
so just bear with me as i run through
just to make sure that i've got this
right and haven't got it wrong
the final annual plan
will be approved by june this year
the um
process
for
uh redesignating the land at tisbury
is probably like likely to start soon
very soon
but that will potentially take six to
eight months according to the report so
it takes us up to the end of this year
or into early
2023
and in your report you say that the
storage facility will be up and running
um by early 2024 that's 12 months later
but in that report there's also
acknowledge that in that remaining year
it takes five to six months to
physically move the correction
collection from a to b
so am i right and suggesting that
the physical build of the storage will
take six to eight months
uh counter to it to a degree what we
have done and this is the benefit of
including the tisbury reclassification
within this annual plan
consultation process is that we're
actually following the annual plan time
frames so that decision around
classification will also be reached in
the same time that we reach
the decision on the preferred option
so that
is uh june this year
bear with me steve but in your report it
says the and i'm i'll just quote it the
rromf
process will take six to eight months
so i don't know how that will tie into
the
about two and a half months from where
we are now
that's an
it's in one of the reports we've got
today but that's okay i just thought the
time frame was a bit tight one one final
question
um and that's on page nine when it
refers to atara
um uh you mentioned that we don't own
the tuatara it doesn't belong to us and
i understand that
um
and there's a suggestion there which i
support that the i guess the breeding
program or the enclosure for majority of
them should go into queens park
any idea what the
new enclosure in queens park will cost
uh i think we've got an approximately
four hundred thousand dollars councillor
okay
thank you and thank you chair for those
questions
thank you councillor clark um council
ludlow
thanks chair um
recognizing that we're just asking
questions at this point
the the options
two and three um are the ones that i'm
looking at and and coming to terms with
the difference between the mgg's
recommendation for option two and and
the um suggestion that option three
financially scales things back
i know that with
a previous project i'll use splash
palace as an example when it was
constructed by a previous council that
it was designed in such a way that
things were able to be added at a later
stage
when they could be afforded
is that something that has been
entertained with this project
it's been
entertained
in the sense around the storage facility
because it's a very simple structure
but with both a storage facility and a
cultural facility slash
museum
that's probably the last thing you want
to be designing into a facility that has
your taiwan and your special elements so
it hasn't been factored into tai noa
options two or three
thank you
right
uh councillor crackit were you asking a
question or no no you're good um
counselor server
thanks mr chair
um steve i'm also exploring the
difference between options two and three
i can certainly accept that option one
there are sound reasons for
not recommending option one
however when you talk about
comparatively similar customer
experience
and i'm not going to ask you about the
financial risk because the financial
risk
and its reduction
is quite obvious but the comparatively
similar customer experience between
options two and three
are you able to just fill in a little
more information there
are you speaking in particular about the
fulfilling of the vision elements
are you
are you suggesting that
the fact that there will be some
international war touring exhibitions
that wouldn't be possible with option
three that were for option two will be
so rare that they're largely
insignificant can you just
give a little more information there
counter i think you've actually
summarized the answer i would have given
which is
both options two and three are going to
be new builds and so they're going to be
designed um to current and contemporary
design standards for customer experience
so
in terms of efficiency
and future proofing they'll both have
the ability to change
with time and that's what we'd build in
for flexibility
where the community would see a small
difference and it's again
they won't know the difference because
you won't have two buildings to compare
against you'll just have the one
but it will be that with option two
the constraints around the touring
exhibitions
there are none
as far as we've determined and based on
wayne's research around the
touring shows at the moment option two
doesn't preclude us from
any of those shows and then you know
there are other factors that would
preclude us in terms of cost
but the design doesn't really restrict
us
option three
would
but only on the really big shows and
again it's a degree of how many or how
long's a piece of string in terms of how
many shows would we get how many shows
would we buy
how many shows would the community want
wayne do you want to add anything
further to that
you
thank you mr chu worship um in response
to the question ostensibly there's got
to be no difference in terms of that
opportunity
so
what we're looking at with option three
is a flexibility of space which is um
would enable us to bring in a number of
those uh external shows as well so it's
it's a very much a good working space
okay thanks is that your
just just a bit of a follow-up question
so
the difference then comes down to 600
square meters of space
are you saying that in ten years time it
won't be identified that we are
short of space
because
if we went for
option three the the 600 square meters
less than option two
um that the flexibility management would
then come into play to a much larger
extent
yeah that's correct we don't advance
coming back we really don't want to come
back and ask for more space
um
[Music]
probably not the reason why we're
struggling to answer the question and it
comes to the heart of the value
proposition is we can't really split
two and three apart
through that 300 square meters of
public space and the 300 square meters
of staff space we can't hand on heart
say there are fundamental differences
between the two and that's in part why
we're recommending option three
because the value proposition is so
similar
and the cost factor is so different
thank you for that
thanks mr chair thank you uh councillor
amazon
yeah i guess my question is along the
same lines um
when i'm looking at the differences
between option two and three the area
apart from the exhibition space which i
can understand that um has the biggest
cut is the functional back of house area
quite a significant change there in
terms of the amount of space
between the two options and
you know i've i've been to places before
where they've sort of said actually we
would have
preferred to have had more back of house
space to do more things and i'm just
wondering how much of an inconvenience
is it going to cause
by having to go back to the storage
space to do some of those activities
that you might have more easily done
right then and there on on the facility
uh you know at the te uno um
and
uh you know are we kind of i guess
cutting our nose off to spite our face
by doing that
in terms of
the
difference and within the staff area so
one example i can give you is a workshop
space
it will just mean that the workshop
which is at in the storage facility will
be much more flexible in terms of its
size and we will also have things stored
there like plinths and material like
that which would normally have stored
for example at
tainua so it's just how we work within
that
model is something that we would
certainly adapt to
okay
i'm going to go ladies first sorry
council lewis okay let's cook and then
council laws
cure mr chair um
in the visioning
i
[Music]
believe that we were originally tasked
with looking at a 50
plus
and
the group settled on a 75-year vision
because we thought
that three generations we thought that
within
the imagination
and the lifetime of the of the building
that would be
a prudential thing to do
do you still see that by cutting
that if you cut the space that the
75-year vision could be achieved
so in other words the physical structure
may be sound in 75 years time
but the
capacity loss will be such that
sooner rather than later
the city would have to revisit the
facility
i think the way in which you've covered
off the advice and the comparison of
service and design against the critical
success factors again we can't
separate our options two and three in
that regard
yes it had a 75 year vision
from a time point of view
i don't see there's any there is any red
flags with option 3 that would mean that
we'll be coming back early
again as wayne's noted
as this is as much about how we respond
to the space but the differences in
terms of the experience for the
community
we can't separate them apart
and so
for me i don't think we have a problem
and option three will achieve all of the
success factors
it just won't achieve them as well as
option two can
so
to follow up on that
um
and given that um
i'm sort of more mature and i've
seen some of my predecessors like george
t.o bob fightery
george ryan and jane davis go down this
path trying to get a new facility
to store
the talca that we own or
have an interest in
[Music]
i guess i'm concerned that yet again
we're being
short-term in our vision not long-term
in our vision
that we're
making a
decision that seems financially prudent
now but may end up costing our mokopuna
but at the end of the day
will mean that fewer
of our objects will be available and
this has always been our problem is that
the space constraints have always meant
that the way that people have been able
to access talc and maori has been
restricted
what assurance can you give us that
making this facility smaller
and making the back of the house smaller
will not impact on
the care
and exposure of talking maori to
the people of this area
that's a
question i'm going to pass to wayne but
i think our analysis in the paper
again is it doesn't it's not separating
that out in that degree right now
but with options two and three there is
a purpose-built storage facility
that has also got the future capacity to
grow and that is being designed with
tekanga
in the design process and so
uh from my point of view i don't believe
we have a problem with either option two
or three
wayne do you want to add anything i
would concur with that
either option two or three provides the
the same
we have in terms of
the storage facility the ability to
protect preserve and present
all the collection items including
tokumari in a long-term
intergenerational way likewise within
the actual exhibition space
where the
material will be shown there isn't
actually that much of a difference in
terms of square metre inch between
option
two and option three
the exception is in special exhibition
space between two and three
council lewis thanks chet
okay this is cook uh reverend cook's
question and the response really covers
most of my concerns
but
this term in option three meets most
mixed most music modes
it doesn't meet some
so you don't think there's going to be a
critical factor and added to that
question
300 square meters you can tell me
can everyone imagine what 300 square
meters is what is this surface area the
floor area of this particular chamber
for example
i haven't measured it out but are we
talking
slightly more than this or a lot more i
don't i think you're talking the size of
a of a reasonably expensive house
okay and that's a good size the average
house is about two 200 220 squares
including the garage for one particular
reason but i just wonder if everybody
else can
because that's quite significant can be
significant
it's
as i say most of my my question that i
had invited visions was answered anyway
but just not really trying to drag it
out but i think
we have to try to understand exactly
what the 300 square meters of public
space plus the other 300 metres
represents there's a reasonably large
area
yeah it's the key here is that
the cuts not coming out of one specific
area or service it's being spread across
the entire
facility and as a result
the services and the functionality that
staff need are not being compromised
they're just being
constricted a little bit
but
the the main delivery of the success
factors and and wayne's team in terms of
actually delivering the services to the
community they can all be achieved still
and and that's where we've come to the
advice from officers is that we can't
separate
significantly option two and three
from a functional point of view
but we can certainly separate them from
a financial point of view
thanks sorry to come back um
this is a financial question but it's
based on the table that's on page eight
so i think it's okay to ask this one
so the difference between option two and
option three is basically ten million
dollars
in cost
um
and the difference between third party
funding for both of those options is 20
million and 11 million which is a
difference of 9 million so we're
basically in this proposal saying that
all of the additional funding that's
required for that 10 million extra is
basically we're relying on that coming
from third party funding
and i guess i'm just wondering
why
even though i know that's come from a
recommendation
why we didn't look at that and think oh
maybe we should just make that 15
million and then add five million
dollars to the council's borrowing
but
if i may just clarify it
you're
going to underwrite both total costs
of the project that is one of the
decisions we've got in here is that if
you choose option two you have to
underwrite the full 20 million and in
our job we have to go and secure that
funding but there is a risk and we've
identified the risk in this current
economic climate some of our funders
don't have that money available and so
we can't hand on heart say that we can
achieve 20 million dollars of funding
you also have to underwrite 11 million
dollars but we feel a lot more confident
about our ability to fill that funding
gap
we're still not guaranteeing you we will
fill that funding gap and that's why
we've made that note and the
recommendation that council and each
option has to underwrite the total cost
what we don't want to do is get in a
position where we commit to an option
and then we enter into construction
contracts and agreements with design
teams and quantity surveyors and the
like
and then have to come back
to ask for more money
and then ask and trigger a process
so this is about doing it once and doing
it right and we really we're facting
that into this decision today
okay council is over
thanks mr chair um i suppose i'm coming
back again to options two and three
and reflecting on the fact that both
those options are
bigger and square meterage than the
current option one
i suppose it comes down to a question to
wayne
in many ways which is
it seems that you are indicating from
your expertise and the expertise of
others you've consulted with that you
believe
option three is eminently manageable
as a cultural space
for the vision that we have
asked and the
[Music]
governance group have very well produced
so you can from a professional point of
view absolutely see
the larger option three
working as well with the flexibility of
the operations staff
as the
even larger option to proposal
thank you councillor for the trickiest
question of the year
the very simple answer is yes
because in
developing option two and option three
we've been very cognizant
of the space
and what is available what is new what
are what are opportunities for the
community
one thing that we haven't compromised on
is the area in which we're going to tell
our stories
the spaces that we have compromised in
terms of size is our opportunity to
bring external exhibitions in or if
we're creating something big in-house in
terms of that special exhibition space
so
both option two and option three work
incredibly well you work with the amount
of space that you've got and you make it
sing
for the community and that's what we
intend to to do so we're very confident
and very comfortable that
option
three will certainly fulfill those
requirements and also that vision which
the mgg brought to the table
thank you
okay right next we've got uh panikut
and then after that we've got councillor
clark and then miss cook
tanya
okay mr pierre i want to
go back to option two in regards to the
um discussion
i actually um i am concerned that we're
looking at the smaller space
and there's no real
opportunity to expand or grow because
like we know
um
the landscape's changing
and our story
shouldn't be confined into the small
space
and this will be able to be shared
widely
and
i think
i'm just probably worried
about we get down to the track and then
we're looking at expanding the
the building or the
um
facilities
but we know that we do not have that
real opportunity to do that
so
that's how i feel
thank you uh council clerk
so yeah just for steve and uh wayne um a
couple of reflections i guess or
questions um listening to what evelyn
said she was worried about um
ability to display so i just want to be
clear that you're not talking about that
you're talking just about the potential
for
back of house and
larger exhibitions that might come down
from right north
and i just also wanted to reflect that
it's reasonable as soon as we go 14 20
30 years
that the way we display our story in the
museum won't be more so much focused on
i guess what you see hung on a wall or
i thought it would be more technology
based where
we could potentially need less space as
opposed to more space so just like your
view on that and
the last issue was the issue what the
big phrase which i thought was important
as well
i mean i'd be quite happy to spend an
extra nine million dollars given the
amount of reserves this council has
but that would only be based on your
current prediction of the cost
between
two and three
because the downside is that
construction costs can
can get away from us
and if we're on option two which is that
we potentially have to fund part of 20
million dollars and i don't believe
it'll be the whole lot
um we could end up
with a museum that cost 10 million more
than what we're predicting now and we
could end up with 30 million where if we
were on
option three which is 11 million
worse we'd blow out would be into 21 so
just like your views on those two about
that
i know you're doing your best to
estimate the potential cost and you've
got fat expect there's any of it these
things can get away from you can't they
um i'll probably i'm looking at erin now
to talk about
what we know in the construction market
at the moment but certainly
from before i passed there
that's one of the things that we're
recommending from option three is that
the financial risk is smaller for
council and the community and that
result um erin do you want to add
anything
no that was exactly what i was going to
reiterate is that i think the point that
counselor clark makes is an an accurate
one is that that risk factor is
different between the two options and
that's informed our recommendation
okay you good knobby
yeah just just a
final reflection i guess um
i mean i've always been very careful
about rate pays money but um
i think this is once in a lifetime this
project is this a question
oh well because we we will be voting on
uh recommendation eight
yeah
and we will debate eight right to that
what you're about to talk about okay
we'll just wait till then okay um let's
go
let's give you a message here
um
the fact that you're changing
the amount of back of space
which
means um setups and preps and
minor repairs or
anything else that comes into back of
house sort of
thing is that going to put pressure on
the storage
and therefore will we be looking at
expansion of the storage facility sooner
rather than later to cope with the thing
now i know we're not discussing the
storage facility in this part of the
thing but we are going to have to
discuss it and what is the potential
impact of cutting 300 square meters of
back of house
on the
long term ability of the storage space
or even the short to medium term ability
of the storage space to cope
in terms of the storage space
what we have uh
within our bubble diagrams at the moment
is effectively a space which is about
the storage of the collection
how we can have a level of connectivity
whether it's by appointment or public or
e-way
accessing the collection and also the
staff work areas on the collection
what i would call the dirty workshops in
other words the um the shed
is something that will be separated out
from that
particular building because of the risk
factor
those type of buildings are never big
skyline garages are a very good example
well lined because you're not dealing
with your objects you're dealing with
very functional um space in terms of
making plants or or preparing material
for exhibition
so i'm thrilled here am i understanding
that we're already talking about a third
building
effectively
in terms of that space there's already
going to be another
two buildings there already
one will be a
freezer which is part of the southland
regional heritage committee and there'll
be a another
container that's beside that which will
provide the treatment and how material
is done because we do not want to bring
bora for example which is one of our
biggest epidemics within uh museum
collections around here at the moment
into the building so there will be and
that is the the wonder of tisbury allows
you to place something on that site with
actually out and affecting the
functionality of protecting the
collection something every day thank you
okay
right um i've actually got a
question that's for wayne i was um
really impressed by the the photo of the
van gogh lie
live
exhibition there and i'm just wondering
with cultural
tourism
to those
like really stunning exhibitions do they
pick where they want to go according to
the space available
to them or do they go just to where the
popular population is and they're going
to get
foot traffic i'm just wondering if we
had the right space that was ready to go
for such an exhibition
would they say will come to invercargill
um no mr chair unfortunately in many of
these instances you approach those
organizations
to become part of their tour a good
example many years ago would be the
davinci
machines
they were only going to one spot in new
zealand
some conversations persuaded them to
tour new zealand which was great and
southland was one of those venues which
hosted uh that particular exhibition so
it's it's about the relationship
i wish it'd be great if they came to us
in terms of of cultural tourism
but the more we have through the door
the more success we have in terms of the
exhibition opens greater opportunities
for us
now excellent no thanks for that that
was the answer
right any further
steve here yes sorry i've um i did
uh advise earlier that i was going to
just clarify recommendation for
in terms of what is the minor amendment
we're proposing
and it is related to the inspiring
critical success factor and all we're
proposing to insert in front of new
zealand is invercargill and southland
uh just to make really reinforce that uh
we're inspiring and this is around the
education program but certainly our
focus is in vicargo and southland
in terms of
creating that curiosity and supporting
that education so that is the only minor
amendment that we're proposing okay
thank you councillor cracker
um thank you
um see ya
now
i've scoured these documents quite
thoroughly but i may have missed it
somewhere along the line here when we're
considering projects like this and the
financials um
we've in the past had workshops where
when we're considering a project it's
not just the the um capex cost but it's
the opex cost combined over a lifetime
or like a a period of time i don't seem
to have seen anything like that in these
comparisons um between option two and
option three like
are we seeing a significant um opex
reduction by going with option three
rather than option two that would see
the project only cost us at a span of um
as uh reverend evan
edwin cook has said that uh over 75
years would be a total of i don't know
150 million in comparison to the the new
bill or option
2 would be you know 200 ml over there
however okay so what we've got here is
we i take it we don't have any more
staff in the in the larger space but we
have larger areas to heat and depreciate
and maintain yeah um i can throw to
patricia who's done the undertaking the
modeling work with wayne on the three
options out to 30 years and she can yeah
about that out to 30 years and that was
provided to councillors at the workshop
last week it's not drastically different
between two and three it is literally
power
and ranks
of course we rate ourselves but power is
the biggest one so depending on the
design build that maybe
you know one may have
solar panels or things like that so that
was just on a straight um estimate on
floor area
so it's not um in terms of operating
costs
within the long term plan we had
actually factored out the operating
costs of a new museum so from
construction from opening forward
there's no additional required we feel
within the turn
length of the long-term plan there is
sufficient in there based on the current
modeling
now this is my question thank you
okay
look up at consumers no right
um councillor scott thank you cheer um
fantastic report team and thank you for
that and i love the analogy that um
steve's given around the rainy day with
the museum and
creation of the new museum coming to my
question um that we might visit the new
one on a sunny day fantastic that would
be a real plus if we could do that
i think wayne just for me
i'm nervous
a little bit nervous just around
the examples we've had around space
and i understand model the models i
understand the financial models i've
done them all i'm very clear on what
you're attempting to achieve
but just from a functionality point of
view and knowledge in the industry in
the business when we look at what this
council has done over previous years we
look at splash palace and the build
there the add-on we've done there
we look behind the civic theatre we now
know that's not a financial model
because somebody from touring
shows coming through there's a magic
number and it's not 950 as we all know
that's hindsight but we know if we had
another opportunity we would do that
quite differently
so so why not guess i'm nervous
are just in the sense of
as long as you can convince
myself and and the council and the
legacy you get we're going to leave as a
council that we haven't undersold
in the sense of
the space
for the future um because i can give you
the example again of
the one that i'm in
um the seven quart prompt complex in
2000
um 11 complex in 2006
uh run out of space now
both functionality community development
space but also
preparing space as well from a starting
point
so i'm just
making sure that you haven't compromised
by the financial model that's been
presented at the risk of that particular
aspect and i know you've done some great
modelling
and i get it
but just a word of caution from history
that there's models around in the city
that we haven't quite quite got it right
so
this is this is a really big decision
for us and it's a legacy that we need to
make sure we future proof
on going for a long period of time and
we shouldn't see a short secret i just
want to i just want to know from wayne
confidence from wayne question that he's
absolutely confident because you're the
boss
that um
the option you have presented to us is
going to work
long term
for you and the city
uh just a moment there to councillor
scott
i appreciate your question but we
we are not right now deciding the final
outcome and the question is definitely
relevant
and to determine the option that council
prefers
but there's still a lot of water to go
under the bridge
in june
when we make
the final decision on two and three
i really appreciate that to you but
could i get it answered from wayne
just so i'm satisfied like you sleep
this evening i i think it's a bit tough
i think that's a tough one i think we've
had enough information provided i mean
we kind of
asked that question but
the way i see it and i'm going to jump
in here as chair is that the staff are
putting forward
a value option and it's prudent
financially they've looked at the risks
and i guess that's what we expect them
to do for everything they come to us now
we can see
that there's another option and it's a
bit shinier
and uh
and we're gonna if we put them on the
spot
to uh to do that they've already said
that
this option three will do
do the goods
and i i think
i think at this stage i'd like to just
leave it at that castle scout yet we
will
be able to decide
come june the final outcome
so let's find you is that okay yeah
yeah all right thanks
okay
no more questions there we're going to
move to
recommendation two
and that is note that the name
will be retained for option one um we're
gonna have can someone move that please
thank you councillor sopa
miss chi i'd be prepared to move both
two and three together because i think
okay look i'll vote
these yeah i just want to do this
separately sorry i'm sorry i'll move too
yep uh second of
two thank you council arminson i'm going
to put that motion all those in favor oh
just a correction chair it's not tan
niho it's just
yeah
so the
should be gone
yeah okay
was that a correction
sorry if in terms of the
motion if it's removed from the motion
then it's
corrected right okay that's just a
correct thank you for that
correction i'm going to put that
emotional letter some favor
against
that's carried now we're going to
recommendation three
and that's to agree to
i'll move on second
one second
right okay we've all read option three
then uh it's moved ms cook seconded
councillor sopa put the motion all those
in favor
aye against that's carrot now
i'd like to group
four five six and seven
um
but before i get someone to move that
is there any objections
to those four
no can we just have the minor amendment
spelled out mr chair before
with one minor amendment is that noted
the amendment
yes
invercargill in southampton
yep
just checking we have that noted
um
if you are comfortable mr chair what
we'll do is we'll actually put
with the expansion of invercargill and
southland within new zealand but i won't
ask talini to type that right now no
that's fine understood that's noted
thank you
councillor abbott
uh second
council of
put the motion all those in favor
against
carrick now we come to
recommendation eight
and um
i'm taking this separately so do i have
anyone move this place council ludlow
secondary council or sopa oh hang on
i'm happy to move a motion i didn't say
which one it was
the
recommendation i'm prepared to move a
recommendation
but i'm prepared to move a
recommendation that we go for option two
okay well
just i'll just talk to see yeah it's
written down as option three is a
recommendation
you're moving whatever it's not an
amendment there's nothing there is no
motion on the table i'm putting one
you're putting one okay i i would just
remind counsellors and absolutely right
that they can move the motion that they
wish we may need to think carefully in
relation to amendments and processes and
i would say to michael morris who is
listening that he might want to pay full
attention and be very mindful for
standing orders
okay thank you
so do we have a second
right we have a secondary okay that's
beautiful okay so that motion is
currently on the floor can i speak to it
now you may thank you um
look i'm
really grateful for the information and
and the balance that staff have
tried to put through and and i value it
and it's the thing
that i've been wrestling with
but i sit with a degree of comfort in
that this is a starting point for the
consultation
and and my suggestion is simply that
we go 600 metres larger
and and give that opportunity
to have
more while in the space but also to give
the staff
something that they'd never had
and that is really good operating room
behind the walls
to prepare
for what's going on display and and the
restoration work that that needs to be
done
um
i would be
nervous if if we looked at
a smaller option where we thought we
could add on and that was why i asked
the question of steve earlier because i
don't want to see us
in a position where we have to do that
because
there's a real risk
if you do bolt-ons
um we did it with splash palace
but if you look at
some big projects like um
notre dame
or
sky city
where there's a construction site
there's a real risk and and the real
risk is around fire
and and we couldn't do a bolt-on with
the collection
in situ so you'd have to shift it out
and i don't want to be in a situation
where
shifting the collection and getting a
place up and running and then deciding
that we need to add a little extra space
and having to shift the collection out
in order to protect the tarpon
so i think
going for that
slightly larger option is
is my preference and and and i
think from the feedback and it's
something that counselor clark has has
has gone to some lengths to remind us
that people are not happy with the
amount of time that they are doing
without the service of of the facility
and so i want to give them something
that
is really going to deliver for them
it's a win-win
you know if if in the end after
consultation we go with option three we
know
from what's in the reports that we can
still deliver something that's good but
i i wanna say
that our preference is the slightly
larger one and if that's wrong
then we will hear it through
submissions thank you
okay so
we've got that uh emotional on the table
does anyone else want to speak
to that motion um your worship yes thank
you
german um
i just
wanted to help with
in terms of this splash palace
it wasn't that we didn't
calculate or we didn't miss the bus by
accident
it's just when we did our surveys
we found that
swimming lessons were
a vital part
we hadn't allowed for that so then we
had to build a whole new learner's pool
um
then
it just
the old people we didn't expect so many
elders we thought we'd cater for a good
cross-section of lyricals
but um
so we
it was by accident really that
we
had to
sort of alter things a little bit
okay so you are speaking for or against
the motion you wish
i thought i thought
no no this is we are this is not
question time this is
a weird discussion
okay are you
yeah thank you chair um yes i support um
option two
and uh while it's more expensive um and
we would have to underwrite any
shortfall and the difference between two
options is
um
about nine million dollars we would have
to underwrite i think we've been
extremely conservative with our
assessment of external funding and it
doesn't always have to be up front
we've got 53 million sitting in the bank
as we speak
we've got 37 million sitting in
investment properties that's 90 million
dollars
if the difference on this once in a
lifetime project
that's potentially nine million
and the staff have been conservative
in their
costings going forward and taking into
account what aaron has told us in the
past
a couple of weeks about
where the construction industry will go
in the next three or four years
i'm comfortable we should we should
invest in the extra space
and get right once and for all
and i'm not normally in this area but i
just think it's worth the risk
so i would second that motion if it
needs to be and it's already seconded so
i'm going to stick to standing orders
here we've had three in favor of council
lottery's motion
is anyone speaking
against that for option three oh good
question
yeah question
certainly
and council clark just mentioned that we
have 53 million in the bank
of reserves can i please ask the
question how much of that is actually
available for us to uplift
patricia
thank you um through you mr chair i just
want to remind councillors that we do
operate a net debt position so any
reserves which we do have are offset
against
um a depth position and
as it's included in the paper as we sat
at the ltp
we were going to breach that net debt
limit so we were up in around the
hundred and
around 190 million by the time we're
finished of net debt
thank you uh
patricia and thank you mr chair i just
wanted to make it really clear that that
doesn't mean that there's just 53
million sitting around in the bank
gathering dust
not available or that simple to just
uplift
okay
council lewis thank you
i'd like to ask the question
how much credence do we put on the mgg
governance group will have spent
many many months analyzing the the
options
i don't want to say that i'm voting for
because you made that ruling about that
i'm actually going to say i'll be back
in the positive option too and restraint
for the mgg
government
recommendations
so you the question again was
how much questions do we put on the mg
mgg's governance group compared with the
finances
uh steve i'll give this one to you
yeah thank you through you mr chair
um look the mgg started their work in
august last year and concluded it in
december
supported by
wayne and a number of facility and
technical design experts quantity
surveyor
services project management so we've got
a lot of technical advice behind this
i think
by
i think we should have some great
confidence in the vision and critical
success factors
because we're all so confident in the
people on the museum governance group
they were really tested and they did
provide i think a fairly well balanced
report
okay well
i am gonna speak
um
in opposition to
at this stage to
option two
just purely for the fact of giving
balance and
also
respecting i guess the
um the prudence and that the staff have
had financially regarding risk
and
they still
and the word they used is value now
that's a key word for me
there's value and um it's just like any
city could in building a stadium a
sports stadium could go for the the coup
de gras and yet it's it's way bigger
than it ever needs to be for it and it
costs a fortune to run we know the
running cost here is not gonna there's
not significant difference but
again i would hate to see empty space
and we've got this exhibition space but
what are we using it for when it's not
being used
and what are the staff doing in the
staff space when it's not being used so
again i really respect the
professionalism of both steve and wayne
and
what they the way they have um given the
balance to option three so that's what
i'm saying
to it uh councillor sober i think
i think mr chair that you might have
missed my hand going up before when you
asked for speakers
so
if you're finished ah yep yeah finished
um
i have wrestled with this matter long
and hard if i was a rate payer
simply a rate payer putting into the
consultation on this particular issue
i would probably
go with my sentimental
feeling that we should go for the
largest possible option
and that would be option two the more
expensive option
but i've
i've wrestled with the report and read
it several times and it seems to me that
we ask the
governance group to do a job they came
up with a vision critical success
factors
um
services and functional brief
that we have had assurances can be
fulfilled with both options two and
option 3
and then we come down to our expert
staff's very careful analysis
of the financial situation the fact that
option 2 carries for this as council the
greatest financial risk
and for me not as a as a rate payer but
as a counsellor i must take on board
that
it is identified by our own expert staff
that the greatest financial risk for
council is
option two
and then i come to the question of what
do we gain
with option two
that our expert staff
have not assured us can be achieved with
option three
and with the sort of strategic and
heart approach that we have asked them
to give to this new museum
and it seems to me that what we have is
the assurance that we have the expert
staff capable
of seeing that option three
the less risky but still bigger than the
original museum option
will deliver everything we wanted in
terms of vision critical success factual
factors
and the services we want and on the
functional brief
so i'm in the position where i do feel
that for the consultation document where
council is saying which is our preferred
option that i would prefer to be voting
for
a preferred option to be
option two
i am very open to the consultation from
our ratepayers indication indicating
that they want us to go for the more
expensive and riskier option
i think for me as a counsellor at the
end of the day
it comes down to we have two great
proposals
we have a very considered staff approach
that has said
they can make a very very good outcome
from option three the less risky one for
council
i would prefer us to go out to
consultation with option two as the
preferred option
and wait for our rate payers to feedback
whether they as the rate payers who at
the end of the day
will take the ultimate risk
as to how they feel so you think you're
not wanting three
you're not wanting the less risk you
want i am i am saying that i want the
risky no well that's option three
yeah yeah and and i'm speaking against
the current motion no that's why
just making it clear there so rebecca
was a question or
a comment comment yep
right
yes
um
at the end of the day this is about
council's appetite for risk
and whether we want to take more risk or
or slightly less risk and i see it as
being slightly less risk
if we were to go with option three over
option two
uh i i'm quite happy to vote in favor of
the current motion because this is for
the consultation document and this
provides an opportunity for us to get
feedback from the community
and i really want to encourage the
community to give feedback
whether they agree or disagree
often we get lots of people disagreeing
with things but we don't hear from the
people who do agree
i would encourage the community to
really look at the risks
and whether they have an appetite for
that risk as well so that they can let
us know what their feelings are on that
so that when we do come to make the
actual decision about whether we go with
option two or option three
in june that we've got a really good
feel for what the community
really thinks about that
and i guess i just want to add that i
really appreciate all of the work that
has gone into providing this information
for us today
this is probably the most thorough
information
we've possibly ever had on on something
of the significance in my council
experience
um
and it has
made it a really um you know i came into
today not sure which which one i wanted
to go for
um and so um you know i thank you for
for the work that you've put into that
and the approach that you've taken and
identifying the risks
and i guess um thank councillors for the
interesting
discussion on this matter and look
forward to the outcome
uh pania
and i also want
us
i also want to support the motion number
people i do value the class
position as well
but i also value the governance opinion
on the matter as well
okay marcus i'm going to make you the
last comment today yeah excuse me i've
been trying to talk per hour i haven't
seen the hand up sorry
it's been up twice
huh he's meaning the electronic one
uh sorry counselor we were looking for
the yellow gesture
the yellow gesture has been up twice
sorry about that i apologize
yep no no you will be next after council
lush sorry about that
i just like to um
back up and acknowledge what bex has
said about the consultation
um
and people talking about the
consultation
in the plan it talks about um
coming up with a proposal that's unique
and compelling
for invercargill and unfortunately for
me
i see either proposals
um both the expensive one and not quite
so expensive one
as
um
not fulfilling that brief of being
unique and compelling and for me what
they do do is provide a brand new
regional museum for invercargill
i've spoken about this before and i
think that
invercargill has
a livability problem
i think that
we need to attract and keep people
delivering invercargill
and i think we've seen that with people
with the doctors and the dentists and
those sorts of people that we can't get
to live here because people aren't
finding the things and invocable they
want
um
of course we've got splash palace with a
councillor scout spoke about in the
stadium which are both fantastic
facilities but when it comes to the
library and other things i think
through council we've missed the boat
and we've come up with things that are
okay for now
i just think with this proposal um
it's not as good as pokiataki in new
plymouth or the lean line museum with
100 watts of things and it's not got all
the museum in dunedin which has got the
discovery center and i don't think it's
going to give us the facility that
people say ain't going to say oh my
goodness we're going to move to
invercargill it's got this fantastic
museum for the kids it is
it is unique to new zealand
so for me i don't think the proposal
that we've got here it's great it's
exciting but gee it's been 50 years
since we've had a new museum
and for me
when we sent this to the group to come
away with something that was unique and
compelling
i thought we're going to come up with a
museum that was going to attract people
from around new zealand to come here to
see it
and i think what we're doing with us is
spending a lot of money
and coming up with something that is not
unique and compelling
um i don't exactly know which way i'm
going to vote for this because we've got
two proposals
but i think the one it goes to when it
goes to consultation
i think i want the people of invocable
to look at this proposal think is this
something
that we're going to say yep this is the
best museum in the country
because what i've seen is a proposal
that just pretty much does and fulfills
the same brief as the pyramid
i think the idea of the storage is
fantastic i think it's a great thing it
needs to be done but to me
this has not got the wow factor and i
think what invicable needs desperately
now
is the wow factor
to bring people to invercargill and to
keep them here and living here i mean i
think we saw the example this week of
people that can't move to invercargill
because they can't get a doctor to see
regularly and that's the problem we've
got we've got to find and create the
best city in the country for people to
move to and i don't think either these
proposals fulfill the brief so
yeah so i can't really say much about
this during this thing because it's
about two options i don't agree with any
of them but i think with a consultation
people need to go forward
and say whether they want to spend money
on this or whether it's too much money
for what we're going to get because i
think this council
with the exception with the exemption of
splash palace in the stadium
have had a history
of
executing
and building things that have been
underwhelming
so yeah that's what i've got to say on
that one
very interesting
who got up there oh council rabbit sorry
about that
thank you for that uh well in my
thoughts the scale of economy and the
scale of size and the compromise the
staff have come up with i think is
extremely realistic
and i have to concur that if we're going
to have a
exhibitions um we may not be missing out
on anything
and the staff compromised and the
off-site work at the new facility for
storage i think
it satisfies all my requirements and i
will be voting against the motion
okay thank you council abbott i'm now
going to put the motion i was the second
of the motion am i allowed to speak i
was going to ask is the mover of the
motion come on no the mover may
write a reply no secondary you don't get
cheeseburger
thank you chair i'll go for the cheese
um
look it's really good that that
everybody is on board with the fact that
we're just
discussing what it is we're going to
consult on
because we're not making a decision this
afternoon there are a couple of points
that i would like to make
one is we're not
the staff i don't feel were devaluing
the mgg's recommendation because they
had different things to report on the
museum governance group didn't have to
think of the wider financial
implications with with council and and i
think that's where staff have come in
with with their perspective
and we we talked about risk and there's
actually risk with each proposal
and the staff have always been
conservative with their figures and
that's where we get to the point where
we're at now which is you know our role
as politicians to try and decide
what we think the risk appetite is
which we will then test with the public
um and that's why i'm saying well let's
aim just a little bit higher and if
we've got that wrong i'm pretty
confident we'll we'll hear that back and
and i endorse
councillor amundsen's suggestion that if
people have something to say then they
should say it
you'll notice that the um
the report is titled the new cultural
facility for invercargill
and i think that's really important
because we're not talking about an art
gallery we're not talking about a museum
we're talking about a place that
reflects our culture
and i've heard a couple of times
council lush talk about the fact that
he's not inspired by it
expectation is that we end up with
facility
that tells the stories of the people of
this land and people who visited this
land and as a storyteller himself
council lush's first tv series off the
rails had not a lot to do with actually
railway
activities but some great people
who told
captivating stories
and there are some absolute pillars from
this part of the world that we look
forward to sharing and we've got the
staff that know what those stories are
and how to tell it
in ways that can
absolutely wow us and we want to have a
facility that allows the other stories
of although new zealand to come and
share with us and from outside our
shores as well if we've got the likes of
the
van gogh alive you know having the
opportunity
to buy in
um travelling exhibitions
is a thing it's a risk i know that the
smag trust board took that risk
the roman machines i think was an
example where
um you know there was a slight admission
charge it did not cover the cost but the
cultural value that it offered the
community was great and and that's what
we've got to expand however
the motion is about
which level do we think the risk is
acceptable
um and so that's why i suggested ops and
option two and that's not devaluing the
proposition that staff have put forward
because they're doing their job by
saying that
because they get us
banging at them all the time saying that
we
want to make sure that there's good
value for money
um so thank you for that but that's why
i've i've
put the suggestion at option two and i
really look forward to hearing what it
is that the public have to say
okay thank you councilor so that motion
on the table
is
for
option two
as the preferred option
so we should get that changed so that
they're on the screen so that they're
ready
thanks cellini
okay i'm gonna put that motion all those
in favor of option two as the preferred
option please raise their hand okay can
you keep your hands up
10.
that is carried those against
right yeah certainly carried
thank you for that
it's a good debate
right we're going to move on to
option uh sorry recommendation nine
and nine options
um this is confirming the location of
the new facility is to be on the
existing lanley site at queen's park
happy to move that mr chairman
thank you council sovereign secretary
council lewis any discussion on this
in that case i'm going to put the motion
all those in favor
against
that is carried
that takes us
to i'm going to group up recommendations
10 11 and 12 together does anyone object
to that
no
can i have someone
moved councillor second in council
armistan
discussion
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor
against
and that takes us to recommendation 13
about the standalone facility happy to
move there and the tuitarium enclosure
second down moved councillor sopa second
miss cook
um
discussion
human
we don't have to um
tell me to come back i've got councillor
clark and now i can come back to your
worship thank you
councillor clark
yeah i'm not not opposed chair to uh 13a
but as i said before i think it would be
helpful when we go forward to
consultation
that we have some reflection
on what other options were considered
i mean i had some good good advice today
from the staff about tisbury which has
changed my perspective
but it would be helpful to have
something in the document eventually
that says it considered other options
and why they were excluded
um
mr chair i um
i hear counsellor clark on that my
voice of caution is around
the level of work that has gone into the
consultation document already and the
degree to which it can be changed
and i see officers steve did you have a
yeah i threw you mr chair look um
what we will be making available
not within the consultation document and
supporting evidence
the mgg report will be made available to
the community so that the community can
read all of the underpinning information
that you've debated today
the mgg report call does describe an
analysis on the locations that were
uh identified and we're excluded and the
reasons for so if that fulfills uh that
question counselor i think that might be
the best way to move that forward
yeah that'll be fine thank you
your worship
can you just bring your mic a bit closer
oh thanks
yes sorry about that uh counsellors and
staff it's just i was a bit nervous
because
the territorium was mentioned and that's
what i got sued over
and the case hasn't been completed yet
or not
didn't want to discuss it with anyone
and uh
maybe the media might
seize upon it it was just to set a
satirical thing but i'll leave it at
that i can provide a point of
clarification chair this is a completely
different project to the carcaporium
that i think his worship is discussing
i think it's a flightless bird rather
than the flightless lizard
okay
any other
discussion comments
nothing
uh marcus then missus so i can't just
defer to um
ms cook are we are real right about the
term tuitarium or does that appear to be
slightly clunky and beyond it's used by
date i defer to your judgment on that
one
i am somewhat known as a wordsmith but
this is not a word that is um part of
tyrell so this is a [ __ ] construct sorry
an english language construct um
combining terrell and
in a um
english construct so i can't comment on
its clunkiness um i'd
we'll speak later on its necessity thank
you uh just
steve we are by adopting this we're not
actually naming the actual
uh before
that is correct right we're just using
it as a description at this stage thank
you
right you wanted to speak um yes i think
too that
as part of what we do within the
consultation
it's probably
going to be wise
if somehow we um
accustomed the
rate payers of the public and anybody
else who's interested and why
tuatara can not actually be an intrinsic
part of the new facility anymore because
whilst some of us have been immersed in
this for months and months and months
for other people it will be somewhat
disconcerting to recognise that they're
not going to be able to rock up to the
new facility for their tuatara
experience um that they're going to have
to go a little bit further into the park
but i
support
the concept
the turtada that we have now with us
which includes henry and his hiram and
the um
the um tiatiawa
combined process
um
will be with us for as long as their
lives are
unless
somebody
changes their minds and and asks for
them back so i think in terms of
what the city does
about something that they say that they
are very
um
emotionally and
uh whatever attached to is going to be
important and the fact that it is going
to cost um
extra is something that is the price of
having a better
facility for all
of those things that were housed in
nehora tatanifa that's the people the
talker the art and the tuatara
what we will have in the future will be
better for all of those
and so therefore i'm was happy to taking
that
okay councillor crackit
um thank you councillor pollinger um mr
chair i would just like to expand a
little bit further on what um
ms cook has said because this is
something that uh the tortada in
particular that is very near to my heart
um i've been considering the experience
of
the previous museum
and uh
she's quite right you won't be able to
enter this specific facility to to get
that tuatara experience but you won't
have to go much further to find it
um the animal husbandry i think is the
perfect place for it it's right next to
our other reptiles it's right next to
our other
um
the rest of the experience that uh that
we already have
well positioned in the park
um and if you actually think about it uh
our climate controlled facility
with um
no humidity and the state in which you
have to have a museum or an art gallery
um
with its climate control it is
inherently against the kind of
environment that you house to a tara in
they need a you know like an outdoor
climate they need water they need
everything that bugs bits and pieces
they need everything that is actually
completely contradictory to a space that
is storage of um and display of
interactivity of art and culture um
talcus so i
i really think that there's a point that
needs to be really impressed that like
um
ms cook has just said that it really
will enhance
the experience having it with the rest
of
our husbandry animal husbandry
experience but also
um that it protects our taco by not
having a moisture filled environment
of its substantial size and the new
facility
thank you thank you councillor cricket
council clark
yeah thank you just wanted to clarify
maybe darren can do this
i'm quite sure that when i went to the
uh presentation
in hiwaka to here from the
museum governance group i asked a
specific question about the tuatara
and i'm quite sure that i was advised or
told there that
there would be a minimal number of um
tuatara in the new museum if that's what
we went ahead with but the majority
would go over to a new facility in
queens park so is that change now
i'll defer to ms cook who was on the mgg
i don't bel it may have been said but i
don't believe that that was what the mgg
as a whole
actually recommended i think a person
who um
might have been carried away by the
emotions of the evening
um
posited that it might be possible but i
don't believe that for most of us that
it was
the intention okay
i'm looking desperately at wayne now
because um
i'm going to play the phone a friend
card now and steve
oh yeah thank you through the chair look
our approach to this um
and where we house our tuatara you're
right we we do believe the best location
for it is around the animal husbandry
services in queens park
because there's a lot of back of house
functions that go with caring
for those tonga
but we also unequally recognize and this
was a debate as as councillor cook has
indicated this was a debate ngg head
around they are actually now part of our
story
and they are part of our community story
and so
we're we're
our approach is that we will build a
purpose built facility in queens park
but we will also provide a smaller
opportunity
within the facility it de-risks the
building significantly
but that's
still to be worked through in the detail
i guess the key decision here is that we
are looking for a purpose-built facility
outside that can house all of our
animals
and then through the design process we
will work through this and there is a
the parks team are engaging with
our partners around the tuatara now are
about the future
councilor clark is that
answer your question
three new chairs that's as clear as mate
[Laughter]
we've got
evelyn saying it
and alex talking quite passionately
about none being in the museum and
steve's saying we may have a small
opportunity and maybe this is something
for a later debate when you design that
new facility
new museum but
i can tell you from years of going into
the old pyramid uh kids love to see
those tuatara in there it's a real draw
car
and so draw cards are important if they
uh they bring people in because then the
cafe is more more sustainable and
people start to get the history of the
place as well so
something to be considering when we do
the design work
if we get the extra 300 meters they'll
be playing football so
okay any
further comments around
recommendation 13.
now in that case did we we had a
i've completely forgotten the mover in
the second down i'm now going to put
that motion all those in favor
i guess
that is carrick thank you very much
for that that's um
that was always going to take some time
but it's definitely worthwhile
um
we now move that's into public excluded
no no no we've got we've got tillsbury
right um someone want to speak to
yes we've got staff just about joining
us there we go thank you
welcome caroline and cassie
so thank you very much for the
opportunity to um through the chair um
just bringing you the proposal to amend
the rural reserve's omnibus management
plan um to reclassify tisbue reserve to
allow for a museum storage facility
this procedural paper is basically an
enabling document to assist and maintain
the um
the consultation process for
the museum to go ahead alongside the
annual plan
so it's obviously the process that we're
following is as dictated by the reserves
act
um do you have any questions on the
paper or should i take it this rad
okay questions
happy to move the two recommendations
june
thank you council ludlow and second of
that councillor lewis
if there are no questions or
uh councillor clark
thank you chair uh caroline just on page
five i think it is or six
page five
and the bottom where it talks about time
frames and your preferred option is
option two
yes yes
yes thank you
and so down there it says the process
will take
six to eight months
okay
is that what you're recommending it can
be up to six to eight months okay so if
we're looking six months
um
there's and i assume we haven't started
yet
so are we looking towards the end of
this year before that will be
finally approved if it is approved
no we're looking to have this completed
by june 2022
well that's not six to eight months away
that's that's less than three months
away
that was for that's from the start of
when we're actually um asked to look
into this counselor clerk so it was six
to eight months from the start which was
a couple of months ago now
so the whole entire process could take
that long but we expect to have this
completed by june 2022.
okay thank you
sorry for the confusion there now
it's fine so for the comments discussion
i'll put the motion there um all those
in favor
aye
those against
that is carried thank you
right that now brings us to the public
excluded session
uh except the
um
lindsay mckenzie and jeff grant
i'll move
thank you